[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 los más
vulnerables un programa sobre cómo esta
pandemia afecta a cientos de millones de
personas en situaciones de pobreza de
hacinamiento o de marginalidad o que se
han visto obligadas a migrar o que son
víctimas de guerras y conflictos mi
nombre es andrés suárez jaramillo
a pesar de que kenia es la nación más
rica del este de áfrica la corrupción
desenfrenada ha dejado a millones de
personas en la pobreza peor aún los
asesinatos extrajudiciales de la policía
son comunes y cada que hay elecciones se
viven días de violencia mortal de manera
que una activista indignado produjo un
documental llamado soft y su propio
camino para convertirse en candidato
presidencial en medio de amenazas de
muerte soft y fue galardonado en los
festivales de sundance y durban aquí la
historia
galardonado en el prestigioso festival
de sundance este documental keniano
narra la historia de un arriesgado
fotoperiodista
fox
sus fotografías exponen el escenario de
un país desangrado por décadas de
vergonzosa corrupción asesinatos
extrajudiciales y represión
ahora hablan de lo que he aprendido de
una manera muy dolorosa durante todo
este proceso es que el cambio no pasa de
la noche a la mañana no es que las cosas
cambien porque sí
y me tomó tiempo intentarlo y golpearme
la cabeza contra la pared para entender
por qué no ven que estamos tratando de
cambiar el país ante la indignación y el
estrés postraumático pony face decidió
transitar del activismo social a la
política y lanzarse como candidato
presidencial crear su propio partido e
intentar una silla en el parlamento todo
después de que en las elecciones del
2007 murieran cerca de 1000 personas en
las calles de kenia eventos que quedaron
plasmados en el documental
[Música]
my life cuando me dijo que esto iba a
tener un gran impacto en mi vida me dio
mucho miedo le dije que no que eso no
era nuestro plan pero cuando me habló de
la importancia de luchar y vi lo que
realmente estaba haciendo no sólo por mí
sino para las familias de los defensores
de derechos humanos dije está bien
jr y la esposa de pony face se llevó a
sus hijos a estados unidos temiendo por
sus vidas un capítulo que imprime
tensión para los espectadores del
documental porque narra la desconexión
de bonnie face con su propia familia al
punto de que su hijo mayor en la
conmemoración del día del padre le
regaló una tarjeta amorosa a su madre
una de las cosas de las que la gente no
se da cuenta es que cuando alguien está
en un cargo público o en un liderazgo
público pasa sus mejores momentos de
trabajo en extraños
por eso creo que en cierto modo debería
haber un equilibrio en el que pase al
menos la mitad de mi tiempo con mi
familia y el resto con el público
entonces después de ver la película
cambie algunas de mis formas de pensar
según bonnie face la lucha política
valió la pena pero tras el documental se
dio cuenta de que no puede y no debe
intentar cambiar todo él mismo seguimos
en áfrica enormes enjambres de langostas
invaden las tierras agrícolas en etiopía
destruyendo cosechas y amenazando el
suministro de alimentos de millones de
personas según los agricultores esta es
la peor oleada en 25 años alrededor de
200 mil hectáreas de tierra han sido
invadidas desde enero ya esto se le suma
la lucha por la seguridad alimentaria
afectada por la pandemia del coronavirus
la organización de las naciones unidas
para la agricultura y la alimentación
intervino para ayudar nutricionalmente a
esta población así nos lo cuenta fatuma
cit representante de la fao en etiopía
hemos actuado rápidamente tanto el
gobierno como la fao durante el fin de
semana llevamos dos activos aéreos que
están fumigando más de 100 equipos de
campo están en tierra realizando
operaciones de inspección y control
de un avión y un helicóptero están en
camino entre esta semana o la próxima
brindis riger nesbitt vamos a medio
oriente los incendios reportados en
siria en las últimas semanas han dejado
innumerables pérdidas para los
agricultores de las zonas afectadas
varias familias dependen únicamente de
esta fuente de ingreso para sobrevivir
ahora luego de que cesó el fuego los
aldeanos intentan salir adelante y piden
apoyo del gobierno para brindar
bienestar a sus familias en medio de la
crisis aquí el informe de jennifer
guevara
quemados y en cenizas así quedaron más
de 100 árboles y varios huertos
consecuencia de los incendios forestales
en los últimos días en siria dejando
pérdidas económicas para las familias de
la zona
yunís ibrahim es un agricultor sirio de
70 años y es uno de los tantos
trabajadores del campo que ha sido
afectado el fuego ha destruido sus
bosques sus tierras de cultivo y sus
huertas lo que representa el sustento de
sus familias
en 2015 mientras decía
he plantado estos árboles frutales
durante más de 30 años entre ellos
manzanas granadas peras uvas y cerezas
siempre he trabajado en este huerto pero
de repente el fuego lo destruye
mi fuente de ingresos se ha ido cultive
estos árboles como cría mis hijos mira
cómo estos olivos están ahora todo se ha
ido dependo de ellos para hacer aceite
de oliva que es con lo que vivo todo un
año ahora esta provisión también se ha
esfumado
en los suburbios de homs los incendios
se han ido extendiendo a muchos pueblos
y ciudades poniendo a varios
agricultores en una condición
desesperada y precaria pues sus familias
dependen únicamente de los ingresos que
les generan sus cultivos y sus tierras
ya que les grava
la mayoría de aldeanos aquí dependen de
la agricultura para el sustento se
cultiva en sus tierras como su única
fuente de ingresos porque dependen de la
agricultura y el fuego ha dejado un gran
impacto en sus vidas
los agricultores afirman que la pensión
mensual brindada por el gobierno solo
alcanza para sobrevivir 10 días y que
ésta no es suficiente para recuperarse
de las grandes pérdidas que sufrieron
estos trabajadores esperan una respuesta
del estado y una ayuda para lograr salir
adelante en medio de la crisis en europa
españa ha estado desde hace años en la
cima de la clasificación del desempleo
juvenil pero este año el coronavirus
volvió la situación aún más complicada
con uno de cada dos jóvenes sin empleo
el país tiene la tasa más alta de la
unión europea el siguiente es un
reportaje al que muchos especialistas
llaman la generación perdida o
generación olvidada
estas tres jóvenes están desempleadas
desde el principio de la pandemia
se van a llevar a organizar eventos
estoy en arte desde marzo
de personas latinoamericanas
entre abril y junio españa registró más
de 30.000 nuevos jóvenes desempleados
eso sin contar aquellos como inés que
trabajan a tiempo parcial yo creo que la
situación en españa es más grave que en
otros países de europa principalmente
porque españa es un país de servicios y
aquí casi todo el mundo se dedica al
turismo todos los castings de andrea
ruiz han sido cancelados de modo que
tuvo que pensar una estrategia para
seguir aplicando y poder enviar a
productoras casting y demás que está
coreografías y que yalal a montillo y
bueno eso es un poco lo que intentamos
hacer ahora para que esta situación no
nos apalanque y no nos dejen
sin hacer nada
en españa 43 9% de los menores de 25
años están sin empleo un récord en la
unión europea en este barrio popular de
madrid las cifras no sorprenden si no
molestan
una vergüenza porque además está súper
desmotivado y hay gente que estudia y
sabe que directamente para mí ahora
mismo no es que sea malo
pero tampoco es que digas
y un fenómeno social que influye sobre
el comportamiento familiar según este
psicólogo javier urra lo llama
adolescencia prolongada
hace que los chicos sean vuelvo a
repetir presentista viven era aquí y era
ahora porque el futuro es algo
imprevisible para ese psicólogo el
porvenir de estos jóvenes es un
verdadero interrogante el apoyo a una
revalorización de la formación
profesional porque en cambio los oficios
manuales si los siguen contratando
vamos ahora a la habana cuba donde
muchos ciudadanos están siendo afectados
por el deterioro de sus viviendas en
gran parte consecuencia del cambio
climático y el abandono estatal estas
personas esperan respuestas del gobierno
pues aseguran que estos lugares en los
que habitan ponen en riesgo sus vidas y
por supuesto la de sus familias
agrietadas y abandonadas así se ven
muchas viviendas en la habana
consecuencia de un cambiante clima
tropical y el abandono estatal las
familias que habitan estas casas
inseguras esperan que los proyectos del
gobierno de miguel díaz canel logren
solucionar la problemática en 2018 el
ejecutivo cubano lanzó un plan de
vivienda denominado la revolución es
construir con el objetivo de reducir el
déficit de 929 mil 696 casas
desafortunadamente el problema continúa
y sigue afectando a muchos cubanos es el
caso de filiberto suárez un jubilado de
75 años que habita en una de estas
propiedades
prácticamente se está derrumbando por
parte entonces aparte de malavella y si
estamos podría un techo que está viejo y
tengo a tiene problemas se puede dar un
fax
el aire salado del mar la humedad y las
tormentas tropicales son los factores
que más afectan la infraestructura de
estos lugares causas climáticas
difíciles de controlar
según das mis días jefe del equipo de
construcción estatal las obras que se
adelantan buscan beneficiar a muchas
familias aquí llevamos alrededor de dos
años construyendo hasta cuatro viviendas
que son para albergado que llevan más de
20 25 años de trabajo la empresa están
albergados y se les está haciendo
bocazas
a pesar de esto muchos de los
propietarios de las viviendas aseguran
que son inhabitables y ponen en riesgo
sus vidas y las de sus familias pero que
prefieren mantenerse allí antes que
aceptar una de las habitaciones que
ofrece el estado según cifras oficiales
alrededor de 45 mil cubanos necesitan un
hogar y entretanto se alojan en refugios
estatales
este es el panorama de los más
vulnerables de esta semana en el mundo
ante el coronavirus organismos
internacionales y gobiernos han
entregado y siguen entregando paquetes
de ayuda pero son miles de millones las
personas que enfrentan esta pandemia en
frágiles condiciones y el alivio sólo es
relativo gracias por seguirnos recuerden
que más información la pueden encontrar
en nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]